bonjour je suis laurent perez candidat
aux législatives dans l'aude mon
engagement en politique provient de
mécontentement profond observé durant
mes mandats d'adjoint au maire à la
sécurité de carcassonne et de juge au
tribunal de commerce j'ai pu toucher du
doigt cette détresse profonde et ce
manque de moyens flagrant de la justice
le manque de courage politique de nos
gouvernants pendant dix ans m'ont poussé
à m'engager donc pour défendre notre
territoire
dans l'aude nous avons des ressources
inexploitées
permettant de lancer de grands chantiers
comme l'hydrogène vers notre grande
famille politique de droite et du centre
sort à tous met en oeuvre à l'instar du
général de gaulle de georges combines
pour dynamiser ce beau territoire et
rendre une croissance partagée et
solidaire de la sorte je pourrais clamer
haut et fort notre fierté d'être au
doigt
[Musique]
et